what needs to change is your mindset is
the way you view the world sometimes
your dreams are flirting with you but
you're not letting your dreams for it
that friend of yours that's always
spreading gossip to you about
everybody's personal life you got to
stop picking up her calls need
motivation watch a top ten on believe
nation
what's that believe nation it seven I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from my main who went
from immigrating to the United States
from a reign as a ten-year-old during
the Iranian Revolution to serving in the
US military to then starting the PHP
agency and the value tainment brand
whose mission is to inspire millions of
people around the world
he's patrickv a David and he was my take
on his top ten rules a success vol 5
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one persevere I talk to a lot of people
who are about to have a breakthrough
right they're about to have a
breakthrough but they have convinced
themselves in here of one thing and let
me tell what it is they've convinced
themselves that what they're going
through no one's ever gone through
before that their wall is bigger than
everybody else's wall that their
difficulty no one knows how hard it is
but you don't know what I'm going
through but you don't know my different
you don't know my family you don't know
my heartache you don't know my enemy you
don't know who I'm facing you don't know
this opponent he's so manipulative you
don't know how the industry is you don't
know how to market this you don't know
the company I'm apart you don't
everything that's said you don't know my
wife you don't know my boyfriend you
don't know my husband you don't know my
parents you don't know who I am
my difficulties are bigger than your
difficulties and that's why I can't
overcome these difficulties to make
space up to you you know it's dangerous
and you actually believe that because if
you actually believe it you are right
there's nobody else that can do any
convincing for you but it's in that
moment look at Hollywood you think
everybody in Hollywood is a good actor
honestly I can name you 20 people that
are terrible actors who have had a
career of 20-plus years you can as well
but they persevered they believe they
belong in that space
even though how many auditions you think
that got passed up on you think in
basketball everybody's got a god-given
talent you think Steph Curry can jump
like LeBron James or Vince Carter I
would say Vince Carter's got god-given
abilities I don't know just have Kris
got the same kind of god-given abilities
as LeBron or Vince Carter or any of
these guys in baseball you think
everybody's got this perfect 20/20
vision like Ted Williams had it's a lot
of guys that hit a wall that had to
overcome a lot of guys that had to play
triple-a for a couple years before
somebody picked them up a lot of them so
is in business but no matter what you're
doing anticipate the wall you're going
to hit it and in those moments whatever
you tell yourself if you convince
yourself
that the difficult your face and it's
harder than everybody else's and you buy
it you will stay where you're at but if
you convince yourself now whatever you
wall you've hit other people have
overcoming and so can you you go through
that wall wall as well rule number two
don't be too logical Paulo Coelho the
author of The Alchemist once said that
when we turn when you and I turn 23 24
years old our brain something happens to
what we become more logical we're no
longer oh my gosh this is possible I can
take over the world I don't know if I
can really take over seems kind of
impossible if you really think about it
there's no way in the world we can build
something like this so we go into this
whole different state of thinking right
now the possibility thinking is not out
there
let me explain to a little bit more
about this go back 2011 seven years ago
I'm in my room in my office in Woodland
Hills Y by Warner Wonder Center Marriott
I have made a friend I had known her for
four or five years we don't business
together very smart guy loved him loved
his wife good-looking family went to
Wharton Business School sharp as hell
brilliant guy he comes to me after
meeting at Cheesecake Factory because he
says I'd like to invest I want you to be
the CEO I want to be your CEO or
president we go build this company to
get us a great that's me so we finally
meet in the office it's 12:30 we're
about to finalize the information to go
into contract and the number we agreed
at this time there's nothing taking
place good at this time with the company
we're trying to build it it's a lot of
work but we've been around for a year
and a half there's some track record so
we come up with this number around a
half a million dollars for 10% the
company you know what he ends up telling
me that not here's what he says is you
know what Patrick I said what's that I
feel like you're very good negotiator
and you're very good in sales I said
okay that's that's a good thing that
just means that you're very smart to
team up with somebody like that that's a
very good salesperson negotiated because
you've told me before that's not your
strength your strength is more
operational technology yes I said so
what do you want to team up with a guy
that is opposite strengths - who's
nodding that in sales and I go I'm
trying to and some what you're saying
with this he says why I just don't know
if I'm gonna get the best deal here I
said let me get this straight you're
getting 10% for only a half a million
dollars and I'm doing this because I
want you're part of our team
I just think you're selling me there's
some stuff I don't know about I said
okay no problem
we went our separate ways do you realize
if we'd a came with that investment his
investments going to be somewhere
between 15 to 20
in honors today and he would have
excelled what happened Wharton Business
School
wait illogical everything was about well
what if this happens what if that
happens I could just almost watch him
thinking he went all logical he didn't
see the emotional side he didn't see the
social capital division what we have
going on and it was afraid because he's
second-guess themselves you know you
know what it's like let me explain a
little bit deeper for you so it makes
sense to you when you're 16 you're a
girl you're in high school 10th grade
11th grade someone flirts with you it's
cute you like it look oh my gosh I think
he likes me
it's nice you share with your friends
when you're 45 you're single maybe
divorce and you meet another man he's
divorced and you meet him somewhere he
comes and talks to you the approach
sometimes is different you know what
happens here's what happens
wait a minute I know what you're trying
to do you're floating with me right yes
I know what you want you only care about
one thing you're just trying to get in
my pants I'm sorry what do you mean all
you want from me is once all men all
they want is one thing skeptic logical
when you're skeptic logically the guy
says eventually I'm hoping I get into
your pants because that's what people if
I like you like me we should probably go
in bedroom and have some fun together
right yeah you know you you're not yes
what's wrong if I'm flirting with you
I'm trying to woo you and chase you
sometimes your dreams are flirting with
you but you're not letting your dreams
for it because all you're doing is
saying I know what you're trying to do
with me you're just trying to get into
my pants of course your dreams are
trying to get into your pants your
dreams is here they want to get into
here you're not letting your guard in
them so you don't let anybody in you
know what happens when you do that you
live a life with no dreams becoming a
reality
do you really want their life if you
don't want that life you have to open
this up a little bit and you have to set
aside some of the logical thinking allow
for opportunities come up that get you
closer and closer and closer to dreams
rule number three be tough I think
sometimes we want an easy life so I
think sometimes we want everybody to
love us and buy from us and so easy it's
so great it's all the sudden and with
all of my monitoring treatments she
didn't tell me I was special my dad
didn't do this to me my ex cheated on me
my ex did this and this person did this
and my friend did this and my boss oh my
gosh this is why I'm losing both those
are all the reasons why you have a shot
at doing something big with your life
those are all the reasons those are all
the reasons why you can use as an
ammunition to say boom world I'm coming
I'm gonna do something big with my life
and no one expects it so rather than
looking at some of these tough times
that you may be going through today and
there you will be going through in the
future because depending on whatever age
you are you go from going to birthdays
to going to weddings to go on a birthday
kids being born to go into kids birthday
parties then you go to funerals no
matter what we're all going to funerals
eventually if you haven't already
started going to funerals that's called
life and the sooner you anticipate tough
times and the sooner you overcome every
single one of these tough times that you
think you're the only one that's going
through it when are you gonna look up
and people gonna look at you as an
example of somebody who is tough enough
to go through the difficult times and
now there are a leader winning big and
they one day want to be just like you
rule number four trust your vision when
a person that's new in sales and new as
an entrepreneur you know starts doing
their business they get disappointed
very quickly because they don't realize
you can do everything right with a
client with an agent with an employee
with the salesperson you can do
everything right and they can still
change your minds why because people
often change your minds people are
emotional beings or pack what should I
put my focus into should I not trust
people I don't know if I'm saying that
this is what I'm saying to you I know I
can control my effort I can't control
everybody's effort I can't control my
attitude I can't control everybody's
attitude I can control me keeping my
ward I can't control everybody keeping
their word I can control me not changing
my mind all the time I can't control
people changing their minds all the time
I can control how I'm gonna behave on a
daily basis I can do the other side by
the way
systems are not emotional you can
control systems people are emotional you
can't control people trust systems drive
systems trust your mission trust your
vision trust your crew say trust what
your vision is long term on what you're
gonna be able to do at the beginning
stages of you being a salesperson or an
entrepreneur you can do that with people
because
they're gonna often change your minds
now does this mean it's always gonna be
like that not at all why the longer
you're in business you eventually find a
group of people that buy into you you
eventually find a group of people that
understand how consistent you are you
eventually find a group of people that
want to be in business with you forever
you eventually find a group of people
that like your style you eventually find
a group of people that like your vision
your crusade your cause your mission and
your vision is so big that other
people's vision also fits into it but it
won't happen right off the bat and so
while you're watching this video and
you're asking yourself oh my gosh you
know IIIi if I land this one client it's
gonna make me $300,000 it's gonna change
my life I can't wait to land this client
if I land that one sales guy he's the
best in the market I gotta get this guy
what happens if they change their minds
do you also change your mind what
happened if they say no do you also get
down on yourself and say oh my gosh I
don't have the business for me no don't
let other people's emotions and
decisions and constant changing their
minds dictate your mind you focus on
your vision your mission and long-term
things that you want to do with your
life and eventually you'll find enough
people that want to run with you rule
number five learn continuously if I was
to ask you this one question here watch
this how many guys have a four-year
degree raised and if you got a four-year
degree okay now watch this keep your
hands up please keep your hand up I'm
really curious how many of you that have
a four-year degree in the last 30 days
you finished a business book that's the
problem
why so what's the point of a degree some
some ants are still up was it just to
get a degree in that education is gonna
be done you know what that's kind of
like me saying that's like me saying to
following when I was 14 to 18 years old
I exercise every day and that's it come
on how we stay in shape you know I don't
know why my six-pack is not coming I
used to have it when I was 22 I'm 42 no
no we need to workout today
right we need to educate ourselves today
not what we did 20 years ago so I don't
have any problem with our
people that get degrees I have a problem
with us not endorsing self-education I
have a problem with the fact that we
need four years to go to college
nowadays where snapchat comes out the
next thing comes out the next thing
comes out we have to move so quick that
a four-year degrees too slow to school
at our educational system needs to be
adjusted
very very quickly rule number six get
rid of negative people let's just say
you have the best mentor in the world
that you get to choose anybody pick them
Pat I'd love to have you as a mentor
maybe Tony maybe Elon pick whoever you
think is the best mentor for you and
imagine if you have this person in your
life and simultaneously you have five
negative people in your life okay so one
incredible mentor and five absolutely
negative people in your life who do you
think wins I'm being serious
who do you think wins do you think even
with those five negative people in your
life and this one incredible mentor do
you think you're still gonna end up
winning he's more powerful you see
there's this whole notion that people
think if I had this incredible mentor
Pat I'm gonna kill it in life even with
the five negative people in my life it's
not how it works
see it doesn't work that way those five
and negative people have way more
influence on your life than that one
incredible mentor and here's why
think about these people that are super
successful how many people think have
worked with them directly
think about it how many people think
Elon is touched how many people think
Steve touched Gates is touched
Tony's touched how many people think
they've touched how come not all of them
became successful they're incredible
mentors aren't they
why is that she because even the most
ridiculous mentor in the world can't
stop those five negative people that
steal all the dreams from your mind and
from your heart they don't have that
kind of influence so that negative
cousin of yours that calls you [ __ ] and
all the time you got to stop picking up
his calls
that friend of yours that's always
spreading gossip to you about
everybody's personal life you got to
stop picking up her calls that best
friend of yours from high school who
thinks rich people are greedy and they
suck she is sucking all your dreams out
of you and you don't even know it
rule number seven fight there is the one
audience that says I don't believe in
competition
I believe in domination I don't want to
compete because it's for sissies i
dominate people then there's a group
that says I don't I don't think
competitions good or dominations good
I believe in collaboration I like to
collaborate let's figure out a way to do
stuff together which is fine but then
there's this group hidden group secretly
some of the most fierce crazy
competitors in the world but you know
what happened to them few years ago
maybe they were in high school group
broke up with them they lost the
football game in front of friends family
girlfriend husband wife they were
humiliated and they said oh my gosh this
is so hurtful people saw me lose I am so
embarrassed
I will never compete ever again I've had
some humiliating losses in the past
before and it's made me become timid but
this is what I respect you guys
sometimes put these up I say listen I
don't know if I'm gonna beat you or not
but I'm gonna fight you here's what I'm
going to be doing I'm getting in the
flippin arena let's see what happens in
the arena if I'm not good I'm gonna get
better and come back but if I'm good I
want to fight the next guy that's how
you get better and by the way that's
part of life as well that's what makes
it juicy to want to keep getting better
rule number eight change your mindset
people are going to try to change you in
two different ways okay
one
there's gonna be people that want to
help you change your mindset you know
and change your mindset and the way you
view things that's a different story but
then there's gonna be people that are
gonna try to change you
the way you are with your personality
and those people that try to change you
with your personality on the way you're
wired you have to be very careful with
that because if you allow somebody to
convince you to change your personality
not your mindset you in a way could take
that as maybe you're not good enough
NSPS its complete BS have to battle with
the people that end up winning at the
highest level you know what they have
they end up believing that they can win
at the highest level that the way
they're wired is worthy enough to win at
the highest level that's the mindset
there are different personalities than
you I've seen people that are quiet
timid and people think they're weak and
they become presidents you've seen
people that are loud and very loud and
obnoxious and they become president so
it doesn't mean just one type of
personality once every type of
personality wants it's the mindset so
don't let anybody convince you that your
personality and the way your wiring is
not here here that has to change
that's not worthy enough what needs to
change is your mindset is the way you
view the world is the way you view
things money life marriage business
freedom relationships those processing
that you have here it's okay to change
those things but not your personality
your personality is perfect just the way
it is all the other things you can work
on rule number nine sleep sweat grind
and repeat
one of the biggest contradictions of
massive success is when people go to
their moms their dads their
brother-sister boyfriend/girlfriend they
say listen one day the world's gonna
Know Who I am one day I will have a
Ferrari the Lambo the Rose the Bentley
the big house the cars the backyard with
the big swimming pool and an elevator
i'ma put the biggest parties people
gonna stop me at the mall mom they're
gonna stop me at the airport and take
pictures I mean take selfies with me and
tell me oh my gosh you changed my life
I'm gonna be a million or one day yet
instead of staying at the office on
Friday night you call your friends in go
party instead of waking up Saturday
morning to go to the gym you sleep into
a 10 o'clock instead of reading the book
on Sundays you kick back and watch
movies all day long see the reality is
very simple those who win big they do
four things right they sleep sweat climb
repeat
and they do it over and over and over
again under their dreams become a
reality
if you're thinking a st. Pat there's no
way in the world that can be that easy
listen let me break it down for you this
whole concept of sleep sweat grind
repeat comes down to a few things you
get to do when you out work you out
improve you out strategize you outlast
your peers your competitors five ten
years from now not only will you be a
rockstar in your industry but that
Ferrari that a Lambo that Bentley that
rolls was that big house with the
elevator the big parties that Fame
tackle is the respect all of those
things will become a reality if you
sleep sweat grind repeat
and rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip is have fun
running the sales office back in 2005 in
Granada Hills okay and I always came in
on Sundays because Sunday's things were
quiet I could really strategize and
write stuff down to know what I'm gonna
be doing the next week one Sunday I go
in and I'm like wait a minute nobody
parks the car here on Sundays this is
not a place you park the car on Sundays
in Granada Hills right off to four or
five freeway two cars are parked outside
so what's going on here so I come
upstairs and by the way there was a way
for you to always sneak into the office
on Sunday because if you had one of
those you know how you put the ID stuff
in the door you know which one I'm
talking on the door opens so there was a
way to sneak in but I came in from the
elevator I put my keys in and I'm
hearing stuff what is this is it the
cleaning crew okay this is not a sound I
recognize for cleaning it shouldn't
sound like this in a moment I open the
door oh it's like you know when it's
like too late when you see something
yeah that was too late already and I saw
it and this couple boyfriend and
girlfriend they're going at it as if
they're shooting a porn movie that day
and I'm watching these guys like the
sound cha-cha loud I'm like and you look
at me like you know the whole look you
mean if you cover your so I'm like guys
I'm uncomfortable what are you guys
doing here
it's like it everybody's doing one of
these things right oh my gosh Patrick
we're so sorry I said why here why not
in your apartment why not in your house
but Pat I live with my parents and he
lives with his parents and our car is
too small and it was a tall guy which is
this is the best place we find us at but
did you stand here on the carpet we
train right here I'm gonna talk right
next to this tomorrow and I said let's
um finish off and just tell me when you
guys are done so I step outside few
minutes later they finish up they come
they leave they're embarrassed the next
day is the best day because next Monday
morning we have our Monday full-timers
meetings we have about 50 people in the
office and I get up and I spot him he's
sitting over here she is sitting over
here
okay so I get up I said oh my gosh I
gotta have fun with this I say listen
let me take out something one of the
things that impresses me the most is
when I see people show up on Sundays to
prepare for their week and let me tell
you who showed up this Sunday to the
office or prepare for the week can we
please have such-and-such stand up and
can we have you stand up he stand up she
stands up there sitting I said listen
guys these guys were here on Sunday
strategizing on what they're going to
to take their business to the next level
I'm so proud of you guys you would give
a round of applause to these guys their
face is so right it's crazy right they
grab a seat I said I just want you to
I'm very proud of you guys you guys
going places so keep doing what you're
doing right now we're gonna see you at
the top
now I've got a really special bonus gift
from Patrick on how to know who you want
to be but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
actually taking action in your life or
your business and if you're feeling bold
leave your answers in the comments below
here we go
question number one who are the negative
people that you need to get rid of in
your life number two what's your vision
that you need to trust in more and
number three how will you continue to
learn and improve your mindset every day
the number one reason why so many
entrepreneurs lose momentum is because
of start stop
let me explain to what I mean by start
stop they start they get excited oh my
gosh I'm gonna figure this out
I'm gonna pull this off imma get after
another yeah I'm so motivated because
I'm gonna do for my mom my dad my
husband my wife might sell power this is
so great and they go from making three
grand a month
five grand a month oh my gosh ten grand
a month 15 20 30 a month and in that 30
ma whatever that number is all of
Senegal from 30 a month to 17 to 9 to
four thousand dollars a month and they
lost momentum so what happened there
because of start stop they start and
then they stop now why do they stop
maybe their stomach got full maybe they
got casual maybe they got cocky maybe
started coming to office a little later
maybe they thought they knew it on they
became this motivational speaker I'm
just gonna go and speak all over the
place that's what I'm gonna be doing and
a business starts dropping but they dose
things become the cause of a business
drop is so now why does that happen
if it starts stop what causes somebody
to have so many start stops very simple
the question that most people don't have
the answer to is who do you want to be
in life let me ask you one more time
who do you want to be in life who what
kind of a life do you want to live what
do you mean by who do I want to be in
life who do you want to be in life do
you know what you want to do is it just
the cars is it just for people to say
you're cool is it just a house it's a
gesture you know money is it just a
accolades to fame is that what it is
what is it you want to make an impact
what is your life gonna be worth one day
what are people gonna say about you when
you die the eulogy is gonna be written
what are they gonna say about you who do
you want to be on life how are you kids
gonna remember you what are your parents
gonna say about you you know what are
your siblings gonna say about you what
are your friends gonna say about you
what's the school gonna say about you or
is it just one of those things boom you
disappear and you're gone and people
come to your funeral one time and maybe
they show up on seer and then afterwards
you're just forgotten about and you know
why that happens because most people
have no clue who they want to be in life
and I know that sounds kind of strange
but people just have no idea who they
want to be in life
what was one long media the most
important work ever
if you had to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
Apple
that would be connect a little beacon
[Music]
if you want more Patrick check out the
tour that I did of his office in Dallas
it was a lot of fun the link is right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
we're gonna meet Patrick Lee David today
we're gonna explore Dallas Fort Worth
maybe get some salsa dancing tonight but
first it is time